17 days away from the 2021 nfl draft and
one of the top pass rushers in this
year's class joins us now live gregory
rousseau he was the
acc defensive rookie of the year in 2019
with 15 and a half sacks one less than
chase young who went number two last
year greg welcome to the program how are
you
i'm doing great thanks for having me
hey now let me start with this because i
said greg
but i see gregory what's your preference
we need to know
we need to know we're going to be saying
your name all the time
i like greg
um i saw that that before we talk about
what you do as a pass rusher i saw that
you played receiver in high school and i
saw some video on your twitter page of a
really tall skinny kid that supposedly
is you
running past routes what what drew you
to the defensive side of the ball at the
next level
um i'd really say like during
recruitment i got a lot of my bigger
offerings for defense and like the
outside linebacker slash dean position
but a big part of it was definitely
coach diaz who was back then he was the
dc
he sat me down and he told me that he uh
saw manny lawson in my game
man he lost at nc state or was on that
coaching staff so he told me to hire
maya
of maybe lawson and then him drawing
that comparison really made me
um think about it making that switch to
that's what i
did you talk about manny lawson i read
an article where you compared yourself
to chandler jones being asked a question
about channel jones because of the
similar body style who do you think
you're most alike that plays in the nfl
now
i'd say either taylor jones because like
we're both like long-lived like striders
you know we're gonna use their own lives
but i'd also say kalayas campbell
because he condenses he plays the three
tech zero and five the nines he plays
all over defensive line and he's done
that throughout his career so those are
two great comparisons for me i feel like
i saw that calais campbell had some uh
some praise for you and said he could be
better
than me now when you hear something like
that from calais campbell he could be
better than me it's got to make you feel
good but it's also going to make you
feel a little pressure to live up to
that kind of an expectation
yeah i'd say more than anything it
really just motivates me you know for
him to talk about me like that is
awesome it's a blessing you know but i
know i just got to go out there and
prove him right so i gotta make sure
that every day i'm getting i'm every day
i'm getting better you know improving in
something whether it's
physical like anything so hopefully one
day i'll be better than him that's
that's my goal for shares he's a heck of
a player he's amazing
you did your pre-draft training i think
at pensacola now you said you're back in
south florida what's really been the
focus for you
pre-combine in in pre-pro day i guess no
real combine this year but pre-pro day
really what's been the focus for you
uh like i said it's always getting
better you know taking steps toward
greatness every single day i'd say one
thing i've been focusing on a lot has
definitely been like just like my d-line
techniques of getting off the ball as
quick as possible but also working my
hands because a lot of times uh being a
defensive alignment you beat the
offensive line's hands you beat the man
so that's a big thing for my position so
just working my hands at all times and
always
get off and also my pad level because
i'm a taller guy so
it's easier when you're taller to have
tendencies to get up high during your
rush really just staying low doing all
that stuff to make me the best player
possible
how hard was it for you to put weight on
that frame i still think about the video
of you running past routes when you were
younger you had to put in a lot of work
to bulk up to the size you are now and a
lot of time at the at the table with a
fork and a knife
both of them both i used to eat with my
um nutritionist at miami where he'd like
call me in the room and he'd make like
this big bowl of chicken alfredo and i'd
have to just like scarf it down so that
part was tough but uh definitely a lot
of hard work in the weight room and a
lot of hard work when it comes to
nutrition for sure and it's paying off
you you and jalen phillips were one of
the best pass rushing
duos in college football in 2019 and you
saw what he did last year and
unfortunately i think he has coveted now
but
how do you think he's going to be in pro
football can he can he continue to do
what he did in college over the last two
years
i think he definitely will you know he's
a great player uh he's super competitive
he's a he's a freak athlete obviously
but he's also a really good person you
know he's really determined so just for
him to battle back from all that
adversity that happened
earlier in his career it it shows so
much about him as a person him as a
player so i feel like he's gonna have a
great career in the pros
i saw recently you accepted an
invitation to be in cleveland for the
draft how long did it take you to think
about that because some guys go some
guys don't was it something you wrestled
with or did you know immediately you
wanted to go
uh
i thought about it talk to my family
about it and stuff like that but i feel
like it's the right decision for me to
go on
it's the moment i've been waiting for my
whole entire life i've been dreaming
about so to have the opportunity
uh to go to cleveland in person is a
huge blessing especially with covid
these days and how last draft was how
the last draft was virtues i mean it's
awesome to be able to go in person and
shake the commissioner's hand so that's
my goal you know i couldn't turn it down
i couldn't it's it's been a lifelong
dream
all right you dreamed of playing in the
nfl was there a team you grew up wanting
to play four
uh nothing in particular i mean i was a
dolphin fan because everybody down here
is a dolphins fan but i'm gonna be a fan
of the team that drafts me that's gonna
be my team for sure i'm out of all the
jerseys
well uh gregory there's there's always
one box that i check when it's time to
talk to the guys getting ready to get
drafted and it's whether or not
you've pulled up madden created a player
that is you and tried on all the
different uniforms to see which one
looks best have you done it and which
one looks best
of course i mean i don't know i can't
say which one looks best but i've been
doing this since i was a little kid so
of course i've done that
that's my that's my entire life right
now i love madden
you've played so many great players in
the acc who's the best player you've
played against
best player i'd say
cam makers florida state he was
monster
uh gregory we mentioned covet a little
bit ago and you're one of the guys who
made the conscientious decision not to
play in 2020 because of what was going
on with the pandemic and look i fully
support that it was a crazy time it was
scary people didn't want to travel
people didn't want to leave the home
nobody knew how bad it was going to be
nobody knew what the protections would
be for college football players the ncaa
wasn't as involved as the nfl was for
the pro teams what were the main factors
that drove your decision how do you feel
about it now that we're hopefully
getting toward the other side of the
pandemic
i mean i'm glad it's coming to the end
what went through my decision was
definitely just the uncertainty and
everything that was going on that was
going on in the time is really just
really crazy times and just not knowing
what's going to happen day after day and
i feel like but i feel like we're
definitely trending in the right
direction i feel like it should be gone
in the near future
and i think your mom's a nurse or was a
nurse too right
yeah my mom was a nurse at that point
yeah she was dealing with public
patients so she saw like
what's the person who was going on you
know
in this process leading up to the draft
and i i've heard this from different
players questions that you get from
teams about why you did what you did and
you know there are some teams that may
hold it against the guy who made the
decision assuming that they didn't love
football what kind of reaction have you
gotten from nfl teams to the fact that
you did choose to sit out last year
because of the pandemic
i feel like a pretty positive reaction
for sure i mean they're just dotting
their eyes and crossing their keys
trying to make sure that i am a player
who loves football so they always ask me
why don't you open up well with the
mississippi before i just confirm that i
do love football i'm a competitor and
i'm ready to get the patterns back on
did it worry you at all gregory that you
you only had really the one year on film
or you thought that one year was good
enough for them to see
nah nah it didn't worry me i proved i
feel like i approved a lot of my in my
one year where i did play you know um i
feel like i did a lot of a lot of great
things in the run game and the passing
game and i feel that i was very made so
i feel like my resume speaks for herself
my film speaks for herself and i'm
moving i'll be ready to get the next
level
do you have an idea gregory as to what
your ceiling is
and what your floor is in the draft
uh i mean i'm not sure i don't read into
too much of that stuff i just know that
i'm going to max my potential for sure
you know i'm going to be the best player
i can be i'm going to where whatever
franchise
i'm going to work hard every single day
i'm going to improve and and i'm gonna
find something
every time i touch the field every time
i'm even in the meeting room so i feel
like i'm just focused on on focus on
that and getting one percent better
every single day
have you gotten any good reads for many
of the teams that you feel like really
like you
uh
yeah i mean a couple of them but like
from like draft drastors i've been here
he's like i'm just like you get by a
team that doesn't eat that hasn't even
really popped into that i mean i'm just
keeping out the door a little bit
you know at six foot seven uh and uh
highly athletic there are other sports
that maybe you could have tried if it
wasn't football what would you be doing
athletically
uh
i mean probably basketball but i just
never had that love for basketball like
i love football so i mean basketball is
fun but it was more like a side sport
you know i played it here and there this
time but football's just always been
that sport for me you know
what sparked that love of football
where'd that come from
i'd say
i said it mattered video game so just
just having that in the house at an
early age really just made me like super
interested in this morning when i got on
the field and started playing it i fell
in love with it even more
you've talked about wanting to improve
in all areas is there one specific area
you you feel like you really need to
improve that to have a great rookie year
i'd definitely say for me just getting
my hands to put this big thing up
well gregory i play a lot of madden even
though i'm old i'm not supposed to i do
and i'm always looking for a good edge
rusher i like using that goal line man
formation where you bring the right side
outside linebacker up to and he gets on
top of the quarterback before the
quarterback and get rid of the ball so
i'm looking forward to getting gregory
rousseau coming off the edge 95 speed
and putting the quarterback on his ass
before he gets gets a chance to throw it
i can't wait for that
it's there use me man use me i gotcha
all right well hey we wish you all the
best congratulations on your success at
the university of miami we look forward
to seeing what happens for you in 17
days nfl draft coming up all the best
and we look forward to talking to you
again soon
for sure thanks for having me god bless
man thank you
all right you too pal there he is
gregory rousseau
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports